bipartisan group of senators have had it
up to here with Team Biden stonewalling
and talking about lawmakers on the Intel
committee left fuming after being denied
access to classified documents handled
by President Biden president Trump and
vice president Pence Senators say they
need to review documents to assess if
there's any damage to National Security
I'll pause
we are left in limbo until somehow a
special counsel
designates that it's okay for us to get
briefed is not going to stand there was
a special counsel involved with the
Russia investigation and and this
committee worked literally for years we
had to deconflict but we've got a job
and we're going to do it I think I speak
for every member of the committee the
the position dni has taken on this topic
is antenna until the administration
stops stonewalling Congress there will
be pain as a consequence for them wow
little Mr T channeling uh but no amount
of stonewalling can stop other shoes
from dropping on this Scandal the doj is
reportedly prepared to obtain a warrant
to search President Biden's Delaware
house the other one had the president's
legal team not given consent and the
National Archives is asking all former
presidents and vice presidents to
recheck their personal records except
Dan Quayle who tells Fox he has not
received an inquiry but he's willing to
check his stuff uh so Jesse do you
believe that Senator Warner is going to
go as far as Senator Tom Cotton and
refuse to confirm any ambassadors or any
nominees until they come clean on what
exactly was in Joe Biden's stuff this is
the one thing that's going to bring the
parties together not being able to see
the stuff they're supposed to be
surprised at Center one we're so
exercised about that no I'm not because
these guys are entitled to do oversight
and like he said during the Russia
investigation they got briefed they got
briefed all the time and then they
leaked but they at least got briefed
right so the dni comes in and this was a
scheduled briefing and she goes you know
what I don't even know what the
documents say she's rolled herself off
from the document so it looks like the
Department of Justice is the only one
that has any idea what's in these
documents and that's not fair because
the Senate is supposed to do oversight
to see if there's some sort of
intelligence compromise and then try to
mitigate that somehow so they're being
cutting out of this thing now if you're
Hunter Biden and you have a box of
documents that are out at the dining
room table you got a box of documents
that are in the garage and they have a
kid's birthday party that day and then
he gets to banged up drunk he stays out
to 2 30 in the morning text Jill hey I
lost my key to the house can you open
the back door so I can come in this is
at the same time he's getting bribed by
Chinese diamonds right the same time
he's fooling around with the stripper
and he of all people
is losing his house key well if these
documents are sitting there just out in
the garage out on the dining room table
if I was a Senator Republican or
Democrat I'd want to know exactly what
was in those documents if it's country
first but everything's been party first
that's what my big surprise was Dana the
other thing what Jesse said was kind of
familiar you know who else doesn't want
to know what's in those documents what
they found President Biden do not tell
me don't tell me let me be surprised and
and it seems to me like they've kind of
made this a mountain out of a mohill
because if it is something from 2008 the
actionable intelligence if it was really
serious is probably not really that
actionable anymore and forget going back
to Dan Quayle Dan Quail is so squeaky
clean he doesn't have any documents
don't worry about it uh if Biden had
said initially
wow that was wrong I should have been
more responsible gosh you know what but
I looked at the documents everything's
fine remember when they did the
Mar-A-Lago raid the media ran away with
a story that he was selling nuclear
secrets yes to the Saudis right or the
Russians and so why doesn't why doesn't
the media do that now I'm not sure I
mean aside from Jesse Yeah
uh judge right now when you when you
think about what's going on right now
the president said the exact opposite
really what he should say no regrets no
there there no we got plenty of there
well we got plenty of there there and to
go off of the point that Dana you were
just talking about when it was trump it
was drip drip drip dripped every day it
was something else it was so the nuclear
codes of Russia wherever he was sending
them to and then we also had the layout
of the classified documents these top
secret documents like a narrative like
for a school child look there they are
right on the screen okay but when it
comes to Joe Biden no no no layout none
of that stuff but here's the difference
first of all in that according to
Senator Ron Johnson in 2014 when Hunter
Biden and his partner Devin Archer were
trying to get the barisma contract
that's when a an email in that laptop
contained information with something
like I don't know 13 000 words or
something so unlike everything else
which was give me this I'll see you that
bicycles I'll meet you here with this
you know thing this this assessment of
what was happening in Ukraine that could
possibly be from a classified document
here there is good cause to make a
connection between what documents were
seized and whether or not they were at
the same time consistent with what they
were doing now I want to say one more
thing the job Jesse as Jesse just said
is oversight it has to do with the
separation of powers the fact that
there's an investigation is not relevant
there was an investigation during the
Russia investigation right everybody was
entitled to know what was going on then
Joe Biden and his administration are
stopping everyone from having access
Jessica is it worth it for the president
to take this heat from his own party and
from a bipartisan group uh is there
something among those can you blame
anyone for thinking that there's
something so bad it's worth taking the
heat from his own side sunlight is the
greatest disinfectant talk about it more
talk to the American public more about
how this was unintentional that he has
great respect for the process that's why
he's cooperating which is something
markedly different from what president
former president Trump did
um but no you you need as many allies as
you can possibly have when you're
heading into a relationship strategy I
think everybody on both sides of the
aisle has questioned the strategy the
press secretary is not being given
enough at least to answer questions even
John Kirby yeah you've spoken to her
I know how to watch television I can see
her I can see that she's struggling and
that the principal is not making her
life easier send someone else out take a
message maybe the messages
can't have decent answers to these
questions no they're not happy with the
coverage of it no one is happy I mean
when you have you know as much criticism
from Kelly O'Donnell as you do from
Peter Ducey you know that you're doing
something wrong here right and so Mark
Warner and Dick Durbin these are long
time allies of President Biden right
going back decades these aren't just new
Senators that popped up the you know the
other day like Alex Padilla I don't
really know him these are people who
have been in the Biden camp for a long
time and you're pushing them to have to
make comments that I'm sure they do not
want to make and you have to explain to
a group of senators who all follow the
rules about going into a skiff and
returning the documents how it's
possible that those got out of there and
also if I final thought on that part of
one of those documents or at least one
is from his days of Center so you're
talking about uh 2007. right so it's a
long time ago why haven't they why
haven't they gone in and searched the
Rehoboth House why or or or his
brother's house or Hunter's new house
can I just say something quickly though
about Mar-A-Lago versus the Delaware
home Mar-A-Lago is a place that that
where there are people being entertained
it's there are parties there every
single night and that was cause for
concern about how things were being kept
I understand that Hunter Biden is a big
party animal but it's not the same thing
as having I mean president Trump is in a
tuxedo all the time entertaining tons of
foreign
judge's point is as a residence area and
there's a public area and the place was
locked up like you have no idea what his
office looks like if you're a member of
the club hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on Fox you can get it all here
on YouTube so subscribe right now